how's it going read my name it's been
five small hearts two's out there's a
call a beautiful your story is here
do you remember what happened No you've
got punished in your nutsack but you're
alive and you're why would I I guess I
could die from that technically you're a
great it wasn't filled with the code
yes I'll be happy by that I call me a
nerd alright so let's start some more
controversy between bronies and brownie
haters is that fantastic everyone anyway
he wants me to play these small pony
small horse cerissa
it was really I'll try that's that here
we go let's see what craziness lies
ahead of us all right sweet dope music
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah tell us -
all right with a bloody smear like this
make no sense but it's okay unless it
was ketchup I always wanted to throw
catch you better well what the [ __ ]
wolves dude chill out wolf why would
they just jump me like that back off I
am watching you
whoopee that's your real name [ __ ] off
woods [ __ ] off Heather's going out I'm a
dad no didn't work hello Tanya
alright wolves it was nice chatting with
you but I got business to be busy back
off back off I know wolves language whoa
whoa whoa uh I works every time that was
lost in the wolf one
but like 50 was and they were like sappy
and I like that makes sense
yes of course I guess we're on that
planet with the Ewoks thing is all right
this is enough I'm sure this will
explain everything
hey do you want to know why the [ __ ] you
are well less than you are siding on the
field here you will find enemies which
aren't invulnerable you just have to
find a weapon got it any objects is lady
but don't call me lady girl no uh I hope
you are able to find the hollows Arum
best wishes I [ __ ] love you damn it
haha
and now if I wonder what's for dinner I
wonder die - there we go
[Music]
big in his music many sweets
okay so let's kill the monsters what the
hell is that here let go starting to get
funky up in here yeah yeah tell it with
higher up
hey that what I need to blind bag pony
dolls
I picked big guy with a brew mistake in
it what the [ __ ] is going on here please
explain someone someone please fill me
in on the details
cuz I don't really know what to do let's
check out this thing over here I'm sure
it's like a magic place I mean this is
huge and if I've gotta fire what are you
doing
there's nothing here really I need a
sword to pick out stone no minecraft
meme here sorry okay
oh no my god Nick supplyin
oh you did good alright that's a frickin
catapult
launch me to Nadia I didn't ever want
access it
she uses catapult you need some crushed
rocks or stuff like that
then press the bottom have fun and don't
crush the camp okay go woho shook hers
let me try if I can reach it from here
whoa okay you can't do it well let's
check over here what is this oh it's
buried people hello there
always nice to meet them specially on
the Friday what is - hello there sir can
you possibly okay hey well thank you
kind sir do you mind if I take it hahaha
whoa eat it taste my sword taste it they
said - that old man all right that is
pretty weird all right here we go what
to help my dead but it what I told you
about running naked in their night Matty
don't bring your friends all right my
date I'm sorry I'm killing your friends
whoa whoa button knock this up knock it
up
well I'm fighting you and I smite you
with Miami don't em Nathan
shut up M not M Shh I have a sword back
off I got magic stuff is not to stop it
now
woken button what are you doing I don't
wanna know that's pretty legit stuff
right there
I mean this happens all the time okay
math Danish apparently against us why I
can't even fight away I can't kill him
in the last nurses that I it all makes
sense
alright I'm respawn that's my own brain
all right so let's go get the sword and
cut the stones and then back up was
[ __ ] I gotta take this take his hand
eat it hey dad is it I tell ya oh oh you
gotta have an ad shoot back up it there
we go no [ __ ] you [ __ ] you wouldn't be I
thought we were friends
piss nap Pest I don't even care about
your friend suck at dancing by the way
[Music]
counter than digging the music
yeah yeah
where
where's my sword what I said
where's Maxine none of this makes sense
how did I fall down the map I don't even
know anymore
I hope the sword is still there yeah
said it no it isn't well [ __ ] me that's
a problem I didn't I thought I got here
somebody shouldn't my sword be here I
think I have to restart actually to be
quite honest
all right there we go ii tried to fight
but it come in don't actually come here
all right machine I'm sorry about this
in your opinion no no no no sorry I need
a sword I need a sword [ __ ] up with it
alright let me just get that and let me
just get you out of here back up all of
you have a start better breakfast
percent in my kitchen
alright so don't worry about it they're
right behind you paid to run I'm sorry
I'm running the fastest I can hear holy
[ __ ] oh they're chilling over there
alright so I guess we need this sword
and that was totally not the way eggs
I needed a sword to pick out stone I
having fun there we go there we go there
we go alright and then Dan because go go
go and I just have my fingers in [ __ ]
this up again okay
no Jennifer no I'm just using you
you know just write me 460 of no
absolutely not Jennifer go
all right I want the sword though that
sword is [ __ ] badass kind of point
here oh he has the broom give me that
[ __ ]
I need me the broom damn it up room
thing go have a UI what do you want what
are you doing here I will murder your
pee and rape your bathtub why would you
do that I don't know I kind of feel like
it you have I have a problem here
No alright I'll show you to your mom and
you know please don't have my mom okay
I'm just kidding about the rape joke
it's not cool it's not cool pity all
right it doesn't matter like it hey mess
you're just I need to fly away this is
fast I can't because I would say the
coolest homie
okay oh she left me a present
give me that there we go I picked up
it's 20% cooler all right I think I got
what I wanted let me just get the sword
and then we can enter this
if it's outside the castle have this
[ __ ] up on counter Kiryas to see what
the inside will look like alright
Skyward Sword come here venture back up
Jennifer I love you
I don't care yourself back when will you
realize yourself back Jennifer don't
poke me pin it down yourself back so
fast all right
Martine I'm disappointed that here I
thought we were friends
I guess it's official Martinez join the
barrels in the head bang bang alright
what is that is that what I think it is
oh all right
I pull out my side the final battle
begins between pity pie of the barrel
let's fight what are you doing [ __ ] off
you're not to catch this battle we're
not the [ __ ] cat go [ __ ] up [ __ ] off
all of you ahead charming back up barrel
and [ __ ] eat you whoa what's going on
here what is he doing
oh sweet crumpet
well my date budget top stop button
magic [ __ ] going in here
alright I'm using the realism there and
that way yeah so I think unless it ends
here I don't know it's usually really
hard to tell
alright it doesn't all right like
appreciate enjoyed subscribe to come a
bro today and I'll see you next episode
of the small hearts too
[Music]
my wheelchair I'm sorry
that's the